[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Austin
are you with me yep can you hear me yes
sir how can we help uh I hope you both
are doing well today so I recently
probably within the last few weeks uh
stumbled upon your content and I'm just
trying to wrap my head around uh I have
a six% uh salary match uh 401k and I'm
trying to wrap my head around foregoing
that and putting in uh straight into
debt and if was looking for an
explanation that's a great question that
means you're being very thoughtful about
all of this very well done so what do
you do for a
living so I am actually a uh purchasing
manager for a mine okay and so you um
have a degree in Business possibly yes
okay good I thought I thought so um so
because you're good at you're good at
seeing the the math thing right in front
of you and going well that seems dumb so
here's a couple of things that we
discovered and I I honestly doing this
for 30 years uh 25 years ago I was
backing into some of these ideas because
I come from the same academic background
but back when the dinosaurs roam the
Earth that you came from okay MH and so
my my first tendency is to nerd out and
fix everything with math MH but I
figured out in personal finance that the
data of best practices among
millionaires doesn't necessarily follow
math all the time in other words
personal finance is more personal than
it is finance it's more Behavior than it
is math and so what we've discovered
over the year Decades of doing this is
that in other words here's an example
the power of exclusively focusing all of
your money energy your arithmetic energy
on one goal for a short period of time
supersedes the employer
match yeah the power
Focus although that's a little bit
nebulous and hard to put a math figure
to we've proven that over a decade
getting clear of Consumer Debt very very
quickly increases the probability that
you actually do it number one but number
two uh it gets you out of debt and frees
up then your most powerful wealth
building tool which is your income when
you bifurcate your focuses meaning you
spread them out when you spread out
light it merely lights a room when you
focus it you can do surgery or
manufacture things with it called a
laser and what we're doing here is for a
short period of time not an extended
period of time that won't the the theory
doesn't stand up and the hypothesis
doesn't stand up over a long period of
time but for three years or less if you
forgo a match and forgo forgo all
investing and in lie of that they have
this
tremendous emotion and psychologic focus
on singular goal of becoming debt-free
and then you stay out of debt for the
rest of your life you not only get the
match you get to max out all of these
retirements and it is ends up being 15
years later the shortest path to
becoming a millionaire although the
short-term math of missing out on that
match for someone like you Austin or me
that was trained in nerd nerdville uh it
it it feels Blasphemous doesn't
it I understand what you're saying I I
feel like I'm stepping over dimes to
pick up pennies
almost when you take the match you are
yeah but I I get what you're saying it's
better to direct my Approach towards one
thing as opposed to try and spread my
Avenues out and which hasn't worked for
the past however many years I've been
going at this yeah let me give you
another example because it's a great
discussion for everyone to listen in on
this conversation because this comes up
a lot and because it there's a real it's
a real valid question and a valid
discussion but here's the other thing if
you don't get out of
debt and you don't change your mindset
about debt and you languish in Consumer
Debt for 10 years because simultaneously
you're trying to invest then what you've
done is you've completely
disabled the wealth building
mechanism and so by simply increasing
the probability of becoming and staying
debt free by shortening the term
you've increased the probability of
wealth dramatically you in other words
you can't half but do the get out of
debt and half butt do the investing
thing at the same time and ever get this
right yeah you never get clear of it
that's what ends up happening and so
it's a but it's but it man I get tripped
up on the math thing it here here's
another the the de snowball versus I was
on a h a podcast the other day with a
young lady in our space Erica very smart
lady and she used the debt Avalanche to
pay off she's a lawyer pay off her law
school debt and she was talking to me
about that and I said yeah but you're a
highly disciplined valid dictorian
law student okay you you know you're an
unusual human being most of us are
normal human beings we have to see the
feedback loop of getting the little one
paid off and sensing some success and
traction which keeps me plugged in the
psychological feedback loop supersedes
the math chain
and here's the thing the probability of
completing the dead Avalanche is oneth
yeah the probability of completing the
dead snowball yes in other words nine
out of 10 people that start the de
snowball complete it one out of 10 on
the Avalanche complete it or whatever
the number is but the the completion
probability is not figured into the
stupid math equation when someone says
oh you should pay off the highest
interest rate first I use the dead
Avalanche which means you've been on
tick tock not in reality mhm that's what
that means and so you know again
Behavior trumps math when you do it on
the short term because our behaviors are
what caused the debt in the first place
yeah I agree I mean when I look at it I
think about it if you look at it as like
a football field right and let's say
debts In The End Zone if you run
straight you're getting there faster but
if you zigzag a yard here and then
zigzag a yard there and then I'm going
to put five over here on this one if it
takes you forever forever to get to the
end zone that's exactly right yeah
running is run it straight up the middle
all the way you know and and take the
yardage you can get and then take then
play the next play then play the next
play just straight down the middle run
it up the gut run it up the gut that's
what exactly we're talking about um but
the other thing that we don't even us
math nerds MH because this I I you know
I've been teaching it based on behavior
for 25 almost 30 years so I I understand
it I believe it and I've got 10 million
people that have done it I've got the
proof text that I'm right yeah you know
but but it still messes with my brain
that's funny it didn't I'll be honest
with you that was the one thing that
didn't mess with my brain yeah but
you're you you came out of the music
background the artist background you
just went this is how to do it do it
yeah that's that is true there's one way
to play that song yeah and this way two
ways yeah I mean it's not that song If
you play it two ways it's a different
song that is true you know I mean yeah
and so this this is but the math thing
is uh you cannot and it's the mistake
that the financial world has made mhm
all of the financial planning world and
all of the investing world and all of
the insurance World they try to do
everything based exclusively on math in
a behavior-based world yeah they forget
about mindset they forget about Behavior
if we were only doing math no one would
have credit card debt facts because it's
mathematically absurd if we were only
doing math no one would borrow $250,000
to get a degree in left-handed puppetry
Come On Dave I know we only doing math
but this is not about math no one would
go into debt to go to a college campus
because they have a good football team
isn't that funny Dave how the math
matters until it doesn't matter right
when we don't want it to matter cuz we
get something it doesn't matter but then
when it's like wait if if we were doing
math we wouldn't buy a car that has a
toxic plastic smell in it called new car
smell and watch the depreciation happen
when we drive it off the lot that's a
right when you hear that sound when you
go off the lot bloom bloom when you
break the curb that was the sound of
$10,000 leaving your net
worth you know I mean but if we were
doing math we would never do that no but
we smell the toxic smell and go oh my
God this is wonderful smell the leather
no it's not leather it's it's
carcinogens you're getting cancer right
now I'm just oh my God unbelievable but
yeah I mean if we were doing math we
wouldn't do almost anything that we
stupid human beings do out there Austin
that was a great question you're you're
awesome thank you for asking that
question but the answer is don't solve a
behavior-based problem with a math-based
solution ding ding